yeah your name's Alex and I'm gonna be
talking to your manager this guy called
me sir like this time is everything yeah
everywhere I go I get called CERN why
would you call a chick
why would you call no stop trying to
cosplay trans people and tell us that
we're why would you call me sir
come back and you're a liar I heard you
stop gaslighting trans people
wait what
did you call me sir again what was that
you said good night sir
Alex I'm gonna be talking how many times
have you seen this video you okay
remember there's the ones that hulking
dude goes into a bodega New York it's
ma'am remember it's ma'am
I thought the trans people this is
discrimination I didn't no this is
discrimination I'm done with it who
behaves like this who be forget the
gender identity problems for a second
who behaves like this ever